it's only fitting perhaps that among the
first to check out the National Portrait
gallery's multi-million pound facelift
one of the most recognizable faces in
Britain
after three years closed for a top to
bottom refurbishment it's Royal Patron
the Princess of Wales not only invited
to look at one or two of its new
acquisitions but being shown the door
not figuratively literally it's jaw
dropping designed by renowned artist
Tracy Emin her 45 carved brass panels an
attempt to represent Every Woman
throughout time counterbalancing the
prominent male figures who for over a
century have dominated the building's
facade
and communicates a new message to our
audiences and our visitors but this is a
gallery for everyone people of all
backgrounds ages and nationalities
adding to the gallery's star started
come back and meet and greet for the
princess with Sir Paul McCartney not
demonstrating his singing skills but his
photography having Unearthed these gems
images he thought he'd lost will be on
show until the Autumn tracking his time
in the Beatles just as the band were
taking off
Grayson Perry Among the Stars out for a
special party celebrating the gallery's
reopening its return coming at a time
when images of individuals are now more
abundant than at any other point in our
history is it necessary institution
because we're all yeah fascinated by
identity now you know we're riveted by
it and the whole and everybody's taking
picture themselves and building their
kind of online profile
and so a place like this it will respond
to that desire for everybody to be a
unique individual
and proving there's more to portraiture
than just a pretty face Katie Spencer
Sky News